es ist ein wirklich wahnsinns schritt
für die astrophysik die bisher
verborgenen materie wurde gefunden die
wissenschaft weiß ja ziemlich genau wie
sich materie dunkle materie und dunkle
energie umwelt verteilen
noch immer ist sie auf der suche nach
der dunkle materie und kann sie einfach
nicht finden genauso wie die dunkle
energie
doch auch die materie wie wir sie kennen
ist nur schwer auffindbar insgesamt die
hälfte der materie war bisher nicht auf
hinweis- und das ist jetzt anders die
fehlenden 50 prozent wurden aufgespürt
wie das gelang und wo sich diese materie
befindet jetzt den klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
ja das universum ist schon ein mysterium
das wir wirklich nur sehr ungenau kennen
nicht nur dass wir keine ahnung von
dunkler materie und dunkler energie
haben wir haben nicht den blassesten
schimmer
ob sie wirklich existieren und wo sie
sind und aus was sie bestehen wir wissen
lediglich 27 prozent des universums
bestehen aus dunkler materie und 68
prozent sind dunkle energie wobei wir
haben gravitationslinsen beobachtet die
durch die dunkle materie verursacht
werden also die umlenkung des lichts
durch dunkle materie aber sie selbst die
haben wir noch nie gesehen gemessen oder
haben die teilchen entdeckt aus der sie
bestehen könnte
ja ist ja auch schwierig sehr heiß her
schließlich dunkel aber auch die materie
die wir kennen war bisher zur hälfte
einfach nicht auffindbar bzw
konnte nicht nachgewiesen werden also
die restlichen 5 denn was wir säen
sterne nebel planeten galaxien das macht
nur einen bruchteil der bekannten
materie aus es ist ein zehntel also 0,5
prozent des universums weitere 40
prozent konnten bisher als gas zwischen
den galaxien gefunden werden die
galaxien sind so weit voneinander
entfernt dass selbst die wenigen
teilchen zwischen ihnen unglaubliche
mengen ausmachen und jetzt wurde auch
der rest der zwischen den galaxien als
dünne gas fäden existiert aufgespürt die
verborgene materie zwar forschungsteams
kamen daher unabhängig voneinander auf
dieselbe idee
sie werteten daten des blank satelliten
nach temperaturdaten aus durchfliegen
photonen also lichtteilchen solche
heißen gaswolken verringert sich die
zahl der niedrigenergie ethischen
photonen und die der höhe energetischen
photonen erhöht sich da wo sich also das
verhältnis dieser lichtteilchen relativ
zur hintergrundstrahlung verändert dort
gibt es gas zusammen haben die
forschungsgruppen diese gas filamente
also diese gas fehden zwischen mehr als
einer millionen galaxien untersucht und
dabei konnten sie durch die erhobenen
daten auf die menge des gases zurück
schließen und bäm
es entspricht exakt der menge der
materie die wir bisher noch nicht
gefunden hatten jetzt kam zum ersten mal
eine wirklich ex
akte karte des universums angefertigt
werden denn erst jetzt wissen wir wo
sich die bekannte material befindet
allerdings wird diese karte eine große
lücke haben wo die restlichen 95 prozent
also die dunkle energie und die dunkle
materie sind das wissen wir nicht wo ja
wenn es mehr erkenntnisse dazu gibt der
vater ist natürlich hier bei pixum wenn
er kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier ein aber aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke ja hier
geht s zu dunkle materie rätsel wie wild
spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle
da geht es um die wirklich sehr sehr
spannende these dass die dunkle materie
will ich gar nicht so unbekannt ist
extrem spannend also ansonsten würde ich
mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran